oh death murder people free speech with
consequences ay public
defend she has 18 felonies did you hear
that did she say allahar do you see the
racism they have and this who this this
bastard here this what's his name this
scumbag Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you
brothers and sisters and dear friends on
this video we're going to be reacting to
the pbd podcast and um them reacting to
this Hindu girl which they misidentified
as a Muslim uh and the utter
embarrassment uh that they went through
is unbelievable exactly the word the
girl outright says she's a Hindu but
because they're so they have so much
hatred and hostility they totally don't
hear that and they're like oh did she
say allahar no she didn't because she's
in Hindu okay and she's talking about
objectively is it because to them all
brown people are the same yes exactly
you see you see what they do because to
them anyone that they see that looks
foreign is um you know allahar okay if
Jesus was alive today because he's from
Palestine say his Isis that's they say
oh he's Isis anyway so let's yeah and
and I have a challenge for uh Patrick
pet Davids in a a a challenge in um if
he can do it I will try my best to find
somewhere I don't have the money but
I'll try to find somewhere £10,000 and
give him that as a gift in yeah I'm
going to give that challenge very
shortly but let's watch this in let's
see what they because to me I'll be
honest with you his his colors were
clear from the beginning when they
invited us to at De Bay Etc was this
color it wasn't Brown was it um no if it
was then he would have to say allahar
exactly yeah yeah I mean this this guy
right here play this and he's getting
others to scream with himk
wait what does that mean and this is
happening where exactly and then by the
way by the way no no Rob go back no no
go to the second fast for like 10
seconds fast and then say let's do this
as there it is guys let let me let me to
you my friends who you are Christian
you're you're Jewish you're Muslim
you're 7day you're LDS you're a Buddhist
tell me what religion you hear this
being said by only tell me when's the
last time you hear Christian saying
death upon anything and it's a chant at
a church and and you can go probably
find one crazy guy that said it that was
recorded but why is this a normal thing
to be said from the other side and you
don't you don't dispute anything this as
a child who was raised in Iran I saw
this over and over again M bad om call
Mad bad om death upon America now that's
okay to say America can you go to the
other guy that the lady that goes to am
let me read the story it kind of goes
with it let say this bit by bit this is
unbelievable I mean what kind of an
utter hypocrite you have to be man what
utter hypocrite
and I'm going to speak P even a
hypocrite a this is ignorant stat what
an ignorant forget all that to a side
Patrick if your children were massacred
by a Muslim
Army and your people said death to these
people who are doing this to the cul
pits would anybody in their right mind
say which other people says say this
which hold on a second one second your
family have been massacred your family
members have been Ked your children that
you talk about have been massacred blown
up decimated gone your mother father is
killed your house is destroyed and
people who are enraged of this are
coming and saying argument sake death be
to like when I say Israel they're
talking about the government they're not
talking about individuals there okay the
innocent people because that makes it as
worse as them if we want everyone in
Israel the innocent people to die no
would you would they have a problem I'm
really curious the utter double
standards and hypocrisy and it pisses me
off so much W that you come here with
your absolute bull crap yes and you
invite as after I would not come to your
podcast if you paid me a million pounds
okay your colors are you've shown us
your flipping True Colors how dare you I
mean this kind of double stand it shows
you that they don't see Muslims as
humans they do not see Muslims as humans
if you had any justice in you Patrick
the way you seem I have Muslim friends
and bull crap you are a liar you're two
you're double fa you're two- faed
individual okay I knew this a long time
ago when hijab told me about the
invitation yeah okay bro just this this
really really enrages me I mean I there
you want to see can carry him watch in
the the thing is he's saying that why
would uh only they say death to America
how comes we don't see it because since
World War II America has dropped bombs
on 30 countries you think Japanese are
not saying that 30 countries since World
War II America has dropped bombs on 30
countries that America has inter fed in
the elections yes 50 governments it's
attempted to overthrow and 50 attempted
assassinations that's that's a lot of
interferences in fact Iran I'm not a
defender of Iran or Pakistan or this or
that every country has it good and has
it bad however if America had one
example of a president that Iran had
overthrown and it was a democratically
elected oh my gosh president of America
that Iran had overthrown and replaced by
somebody else that then oppressed the
population I'm sure America would hold a
deep rooted enmity towards Iran that's
exactly what happened to Iran search
this up in 1951 their democratically
elected leader Muhammad mosad was
removed yeah was removed under Operation
Ajax you can search this up self so
bearing all of this in mind in fact n
did a qualitative study from 0 to 2008
and he said which theology which
religion has committed the most crimes
yes top of the list was Islam
No Muslims no it was Christianity on on
the list on the list atheism no number
one was Christianity with 178
million wow number two Pi guess what
number two was you need to sh let me say
something number number two you have to
be quiet because he is Christian number
two it's the Muslims no it was the
anti-theists anti-theists anti-theists
yeah people that don't believe in a god
with
124 million okay next is the Muslims no
Islam comes at number four with and look
Christianity had 178 million yes Islam
31 million wow that's comparatively and
the way things are framed in our Global
sphere I'll tell you why I'll tell you
why you keep hearing about Islam because
your own Georgia State University has
told you in a study that when the
culprits are Muslims they get four and a
half times more coverage than a white
man on the media Jack Shaheen's told us
and he's looked at hundreds of movies
and he said only only a minute School a
few let me tell you an exact amount Jack
Shaheen actually said he looked at 900
movies uh from 1896 to 2000 and he said
only out of those 900 movies only 12
Movies showed Arabs to be in a good
light so Patrick Bet David just seems to
be just any other ignoramus that watches
his movies that doesn't know these
studies that is blind to the 30
countries that America has dropped bombs
on and you know what America's the only
country that's dropped a nuclear weapon
on a country that was ready to surrender
whoo yeah exactly they no no no no no
people are when I say oh what do you
mean they were ready to surrender I'll
tell you your own Guy Howard Zen in a
people's history of America he says that
the United States strategic bomb survey
that was set up in 1944 to study the
attack of the war they also said that
Japan was ready to surrender yes and if
you look military analyst in the times
analyst Hansen bwin and you can just
read this up yourself I'm on page 422
they were ready to surrender and you
know what and you know what 100,000
Japanese Dead 3 Days Later another bomb
dropped 50,000 Dead who did did Iran
drop Iran doesn't even have nuclear
weapons exactly not only that they
killed no I'm not saying that look
American people are bad I'm saying your
policies have been bad your
interferences have been bad according to
international law of course people are
going to be pissed off you can't expect
to go out and beat that crap out of
people and then be shocked when they
come knocking on your door shouting at
you and and you are the same person who
believes that Islam is the onlyon that
does that that's why you are expressing
your ignorant hatred like if that was
true true then we will say you know what
what you're saying is true therefore we
understand where your hatred towards
Islam is coming from that's not even
true it's ignorant he just gave you
facts on based based he gave you facts
why people hate America the government
the policies and they are right you are
coming from an ignorant source that it's
only Muslims doing it and look it
bothers you and you speak out against it
vocally so what about the people who
have actually gone through those Horrors
themselves let's just carry on for me
Israel protest are charged with threats
against California mayor city council
member says it says to City to the mayor
we'll murder you go to the first one the
second one well watch this here tell me
if this is healthy go ahead Rob other
than you don't like when people come and
hold you guys accountable for
introducing ceasefire resolutions the
only escalation in violence has been by
you all and so there's no need to
continue in the last 5 years I've
attended City Council meetings there's
never been metal detectors there's never
been more cops the only reason you're
doing it okay now watch this okay this
lady on the left the lady on the left
right now grabs that cop see the the
council woman the way on the left she
goes hey grab her that's a threat with
the judge the
the Mr yep Mr that was a threat boom
done what you said at the end and so the
officers are going to escort you out
good for now go to the next video
showing how she reacts with watch this
uhoh death murder people free spech with
consequences auty public
defender she has 18 felonies did you
hear that did she say allahar do you see
the racism they have and this who this
this bastard here this what's his name
this scumbag what's his name this little
flipping it was him yeah him this G back
who is he what's his name Adam something
yeah I don't know what his name is that
flipping absolute clown over here yeah
you can see man you support the Israel
the Zionist government that's coming
massacr so you can see the racism they
have P Patrick pet David and this
scumbag bastard next to him as well yeah
you can see this is allahar you flip him
moreon if you listen carefully she's
saying I'm a Hindu she's talking about
Hindu um Hindu celebrations the
religious celebration yeah I don't know
what it was she mentioned that yeah okay
she's a flip been Hindu you are so damn
racist that you think that this person
is a Muslim that is the level of hatred
you have and she's held on a $1 million
Bond so for everybody I'm 100% free
speech say whatever you want death to
America murder you in your homes but you
can have it but it comes with
consequences so good for her good for
her oh so so on it comes with
consequences so one again so it comes
with consequences so if somebody so
there's no uh freedom of consequence
there's freedom of expression or freedom
of okay good so we're saying that when
individuals go and say things against
Muslims
and then there are idiots who go and
carry out dumb things this is the point
we're seeing the concept for her was
legally for it could have been that
somebody can see that as a a nationalist
person and say you know what I'm going
to take her out so the the point is the
hypoc where are the consequences for the
people that are going and fighting for
the IDF and committing clearly what is
seen by International courts as a
genocide they come back nothing happens
to them people are saying that you know
what no one is innocent in Palestine
these aren't just random people in a
place these are elected officials and
people are celebrating them taking the
Israeli flag the Israeli flag is C
celebratory celebratory of taking and of
you know what occupation let's say of
settler colonialism yeah let's just
occupy settler occupy colonialism that's
what it is that's a reality so where are
the consequences over here you guys can
say what you want over here but somebody
over there oh he said this and he said
that the amount of disgusting statements
we've heard of people whether they
America in us and they've been allowed
to say it here in the UK you say
something against a certain Community
the Prime Minister comes out in defense
but when it comes to people of other
races and other religions silence
nothing exactly you guys hypocrit and
it's a a clear challenge to Patrick pet
David if you can someone can cut this in
send it to him yeah £10,000 you're a
businessman yeah it says I'm making an
offer you can't refuse okay not that you
need £10,000 okay and not that I don't
know if I even have £10,000 I I'll try
to cuz I know you cannot even find it
please go find me a s similar verse in
the Quran the Sunnah the entire Islamic
literature from your verse that your
friend there on the right the Zionist
bastard who's using the Old Testament to
carry Massacre okay find a similar verse
in the first Samuel like amikit where
your Benjamin ano the filthy scumbag
bastard yeah who quoted what am done to
us yeah go to amikit First Samuel CH 15:
2 to3 go to amikit and kill men women
children babies donkey oh
please find me you're talking about that
Islam promotes violence please show me
anywhere look anywhere any take your
time anywhere in the Quran the Hadith
anywhere that it tells you clearcut
unambiguous the primary sources primary
source material breing please kill men
kill women kill children kill babies
kill donkeys please the exact word not
only is it quoted in your Bible your Old
Testament they are enacting that thean
cers did your Christian Crusaders did
this in history yes they would Massacre
everybody okay and not only that they
are doing it today in Israel yes the
stolen landd which is insh one day going
to be Palestine again so I'm asking a
simple question please show me a single
verse with a direct command from God to
do this to another Nation please just
one that's all I'm asking you and you
will never be able to and that's why
with us we are morally consistent you
are strategically consistent and that's
being apparent and not only that I
believe you're a racist to think this
Hindu woman is a Muslim it just shows
you anyone that's brown maybe you look
in the mirror and go to yourself oh look
look have you seen that terrorist oh and
you realiz it's yourself any last words
you know what this is somebody that I
think if he was to get a tan and he
looks in the mirror he' probably uh
start condemning him a Muslim in the
house yeah there's a Muslim in the house
yeah waste man that's what you are
brother and sisters till next
time the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam said whoever builds a Masid for
the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subh T
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atam weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masjid oh Allah
you helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you've
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]